عندما أقوم بهذا التحول ، يتم
تأديتي كامرأة بالنسبة لي ، فإن
الحفاظ على التقاليد أمر مهم
لأن التقليد هو هوية
البلد ، والرقص عبر الجنس هو عندما
يلعب دور الذكور والإناث من قبل رجل واحد باستخدام أقنعة الأزياء
والحركة  الراقصون قادرون على
الانتقال بسهولة بين
الشخصيتين الجندريتين اللتين يلعبان فيهما ،
اسمي دافينا نيكولا ، أنا راقصة عابرة للجنس
من إندونيسيا في الماضي ، كان
الذكور يلعبون أدوارًا نسائية وعروضًا
في مكانها ، وعلى الرغم من أنه
يُسمح للنساء الآن بالأداء من خلال  تلك
القواعد القديمة ولدت هذه الرقصة الجديدة في أيرلندا
عندما كنت صغيرًا جدًا منذ أن كنت
طفلة كنت أحب أن أرتدي ملابسي كامرأة
ثم في الواقع أدركت أن الكثير من
الانتقالات في إندونيسيا لدينا نوع من
هذه الموهبة كان هناك الكثير في
الواقع  ميل تريد أن تكون راقصة ، فإن
حركات الرقص نفسها هي رحمة.
ppear أصيلة قدر
الإمكان
، جئت لأستغرق حوالي 20 عامًا من
رد فعل الجمهور الذي أعتمد عليه في
أداء الأشخاص في وقت ما تمامًا ،
يبدو قمري العملاق
سريعًا في وقت ما أيضًا في البداية
أشعر بالأذى وأود منك أن تقول
أنا فقط أتجاهل النقد وأستمر في التطور وأثبت من خلال
المجتمع أنه يمكنني القيام بهذا النوع من
تغيير وتيرة اليوم تسافر dduk
حول العالم لتعليم الناس حول هذا
الرقص المليء بالرقص الذي يحافظ على الثقافة
والتقاليد للأجيال القادمة و  من خلال
القيام بذلك ، فإنه يحدث فرقًا في
محو وصمات العار التي واجهها الراقصون ،
وأتمنى أن يفهم المجتمع أكثر من
أين جاء هذا التحول التقليدي بين الجنسين
من
تاريخ ما والغرض من
dystrophin
ثم يقولون إنهم يريدون
[موسيقى]